wir haben uns hier im deutschen sind
nicht mehr hier
so ist es uns in den letzten wochen
häufiger ärger niemand mehr da keiner
möchte mit uns sprechen die frau
multivan umgezogen
wir sind auf der suche nach den
hintermännern von das volk gegen korona
eine initiative aus dem umfeld der
querdenker bewegung
bei der geht es offenbar nicht nur um
die korona politik sondern auch um viel
geld
liebe vermögen steht aus die initiative
bittet ihre anhänger innen um spenden
wo die landen ist häufig völlig unklar
insofern sind ja im sinne von
transparenz von vertrauen schaffung sehr
sehr viele fragen offen
die fragen wollen wir in diesem video
beantworten
das ist ohne elfenkämper der autor
dieses verfahren treffen und das ist
daniel laufer von netzpolitik.org
gemeinsam stoßen wir auf scheinfirmen
und leere büros fühlen uns durch
quellcode handelsregister rufen
unbekannte telefonnummern an am ende
stoßen wir auf diesen mann kamera steht
er hinter das volk gegen korona
[Musik]
den 29 august anmelden
tausende demonstrieren einfache bürger
nehmen hat sie's reichs bürger und
anhänger innen des verschwörungs mythos
cuaron auf der hauptbühne von querdenken
an der berliner siegessäule werden die
korona maßnahmen kritisiert und es wird
viel geld sagt würdig sind beide
unternehmer und möchten ganz gerne klage
paten als auch mutig macher unterstützen
und spenden heute 100.000 euro das geld
das ihr gesammelt wird gilt dem kampf
gegen die staatlichen gerona maßnahmen
die scheckübergabe in berlin soll nur
der anfang sein
ein aufruf zu weiteren großspenden
lieben vermögenden in deutschland und
europa steht aus der scheck über 100.000
euro von ende august hat zwei empfänger
mutig macher und klage paar klage paten
unterstützt den juristischen kampf gegen
die korona schutzmaßnahmen gründer ist
ralf ludwig einer der wichtigsten
anwälte der szenen ludwig tritt auch als
schirmherr einer anderen initiative in
erscheinung es gibt jetzt auch eine
seite da bin ich der schirmherr die
heißt das volk gegen korona deren ziel
zitat die zeit ist reif für die grösste
klage in der deutschen geschichte
dafür brauchen sie spenden zitat geld
ist macht zusammen schaffen wir das
das volk gegen korona grösste klage in
der deutschen geschichte klingt groß
deswegen schauen wir uns das etwas
genauer an
die website geht im juli an den start
und wirbt mit schirmherr ralf ludwig der
soll die spendensammlung koordinieren
und die ordnungsgemäße nutzung der
gelder überwachen
fragen zum spendenkonto sollte er also
mühelos beantworten können szenen einer
corona demo in köln
diese
völlig unklar
er weist der schirmherr nicht wohin das
geld der initiative fließt warum kennt
er die auslandskonten nicht neben dem
anwalt ludwig wird eine weitere
prominente szene figur für die
initiative modus schiffmann eigentlich
hno arzt meine wenigkeit zusätzlicher
schirme also wir halten diese initiative
für gut schiffmann ist eines der
prominentesten gesichter der bewegung
auf seinem telegramm kanal versorgt er
seine 89.000 follower ihnen mit solchen
botschaften kinder stärke bin die es
nicht gibt
jan rate ist experte für
rechtsextremismus und beobachtet
querdenken wodurch schiffmann nutzt
inzwischen auch das thema kinder um
seine botschaften zu emotionalisieren
und damit auch zu radikalisieren und
daraus ziehen dann andere menschen
radikalere schlüssel in zukunft auch
gegen die vermeintlich schuldigen
vorzugehen
die kinder ermorden würden der anwalt
ralph ludwig und der hno-arzt bordeaux
schiffmann zwei männer im zentrum der
querdenken bewegung die mit ihren
gesichtern für großzügige spenden
wofür das eingesammelte geld dient und
wie genau die grösste klage der
deutschen geschichte aussehen soll
das erfahren die spender in nicht wirken
lange zeit versucht von ralf ludwig und
ein buddelschiff man antworten zu
erhalten
bezüglich ihrer beteiligung bei das volk
gegen korona sie haben wir noch an
unsere fragen nicht beantwortet wie
beginn die recherche im impressum der
seite und stoßen auf den namen einer
firma in den niederlanden medical
research systems und eine belgische
bankverbindung wir fragen uns wieso
fließt das geld ahnungsloser spender
ihnen ins ausland was passiert damit wer
profitiert davon
burkhard wilke vergibt spendensiegel und
prüft organisationen im auftrag des dzd
zeige ihm die website wenn man von lagen
der website ausgeht das volk gegen
korona da würde man erwarten dass da ein
träger verein dahinter steht eine
größere initiative die sich auch auf der
website dann zu erkennen gibt es ist
weder erkennbar wer konkret für die
firma verantwortung trägt noch ob es
etwa aufsichtsgremien innerhalb dieser
organisation gibt insofern sind eher im
sinne von transparenz von vertrauen
schaffung sehr sehr viele fragen offen
im impressum steht nur die
niederländische firma und eine deutsche
telefonnummer
wir rufen an die telefonnummer bringt
uns nicht weiter
offenbar sind die organisatoren nicht
daran interessiert auskunft zu geben
hinter das volk gegen korona steckt die
firma medical research systems gemeldet
in den niederlanden
wir haben ins niederländische
handelsregister geschaut und dort nach
der adresse gesucht und dem medical
research systems gemeldet ist an dieser
adresse haben wir noch ungefähr 50
weitere firmen gefunden
wir sind die 50 firmen die zusammen mit
medical research systems dort angeblich
an der gleichen adresse ihr büro hat die
fahren nach kerkrade in den niederlanden
rund 60 kilometer westlich von köln
hier sollen medical research systems
setzen wir finden ein bürogebäude einer
firma mit dem namen black pearl of show
da kommt ihm ab ich bin auf der suche
nach medical research systems und die
sollen laut adresse hier sein und die
frage ist jetzt wie büroräume oder wie
sind sie mit ihrer firma wir haben eine
neue adresse
also wenn ihr über 50 über 50 firmen
sind hat dann jeder film manche sagen
das büro oder 60 sind keine 50 starten
die und wenn ihnen einen größer werden
medical research systems scheint weiter
gezogen obwohl das hier die adresse aus
dem impressum ist auf die
verantwortlichen stoßen wir hier also
nicht die richtung fahren aber dass du
das dann legen wir denn jetzt schicken
kannst dass ich die adresse haben war
[Musik]
auf dem weg nach salmen schickt uns
daniel den neuen adress eintrag aus dem
handelsregister hierhin soll medical
research systems umgezogen sein wieder
eine niederländische kleinstadt in 2 min
finden wir unter der adresse ein
unscheinbares gebäude im stadtkern wie
klingeln bei der hausverwaltung sind auf
der suche nach medical research
ich verstehe nicht warum sie das wissen
wollen könnten dann recherchieren die
leute in deutschland sammeln dann aber
ins ausland
ja aber ich kann davon nichts die firma
macht weiß ich nicht auch im schwimmen
keine spur von medical research systems
später erklärt uns der geschäftsführer
einer firma aus dem bürogebäude
telefonisch ins warmen wollte medical
research systems ein büro beziehen aber
bis jetzt sei noch niemand dort gewesen
nach dem ausflug in die niederlande mehr
fragen als antworten wieder in berlin
der niederländische
handelsregisterauszug von medical
research systems gibt noch einen
weiteren wichtigen hinweis
den namen des geschäftsführers dennis
haberschuss wer dieser deines
haberschuss ist und in welcher
verbindung eher zu ludwig und schöpft
man steht das wussten wir zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch nicht dennis haberschuss
verantwortet also die geschäfte der
medical research systems der firma
hinter das volk gegen korona sein name
steht zunächst aber nicht im impressum
von ein volk gegen korona die spender
innen erfahren nichts von ihm erst im
laufe der recherche taucht haberschuss
name plötzlich im impressum der
initiative auf wer ist denn es
haberschuss der mit seiner
niederländischen firma geld für die
grösste klage der deutschen geschichte
einsammelt und wo steckt er
wir stoßen auf weitere projekte und ein
unternehmen das er einst angemeldet hat
novum sanitas und finden ein altes
werbevideo von 2017 auf youtube die
firma vertrieb sogenannte lebenswelt
stabilisatoren amulette die einen
positiven einfluss auf die gesundheit
haben soll
für 299 euro angemeldet war die firma
entstanden eine kleinstadt rund eine
stunde von berlin entfernt finden wir
ihn dort suchen wo sanitas nur um
sanitas gibt es hier nicht gibt es hier
nicht aber es war ja mal das war ja mal
hier oder
ja das war mal 2013 okay wie die mutter
von deines aber schuss alles klar
verstehe
wissen sie wo ich denn dennis jetzt
finde ich habe keine ahnung
es ist als jagten wie ein phantom
überall wo wir die hintermänner von das
volk gegen korona vermuten sind sie
nicht erfolgreicher sind wir bei unserer
internet recherche hier finden
verschiedene social media profile von
der initiative das volk gegen korona und
dennis haberschuss dadurch wissen wir
wir aussieht wie lassen tausende demo
bilder vergangener anti corona proteste
durch eine bild software auswerten und
tatsächlich haberschuss war im august
auf der demo in berlin auf der demo
maschinen auch rechtsextreme und
reichsburg diese behaupten deutschland
sei noch immer von den alliierten müsse
auch haberschuss fällt mit ähnlichen
äußerungen auf im april schreibt der us
präsident donald trump auf twitter an
sie sind der oberbefehlshaber der
besatzung in deutschland bitte schicken
sie ihre soldaten nach berlin und
beseitigen sie die korrupte pseudo
regierung bringen sie den frieden zurück
nach deutschland europa und in die welt
ein aufruf zum sturz der bundesregierung
verfasst von dem mann der nie geld
sammelt
vermeintlich größte klage der deutschen
geschichte corona leugner esoteriker und
reichs bürger vieles davon trifft man
auf den chor ohne kinos aber und laster
verbindet sie themen wie krankheit und
gesundheit sind nicht nur in
verschwörungs ideologischen milieus
dauerpräsent sondern auch in der
esoterik alternative oder so genannte
alternative heilmethoden sind dort ein
dauerthema und über diese themen können
sich verschwörungs ideologische und
esoterischem news treffen wir haben den
es aber schuss zwar auf fotos in berlin
entdeckt wissen aber noch immer nicht wo
er wohnt wir gehen noch einmal zurück
zum handelsregister und wählen die dort
hinterlegten niederländische
telefonnummer
diese bringt uns auf eine neue spur ein
neuer name taucht auf ich dachte dann
geht vielleicht irgendeine firma in den
niederlanden dran
bei der die telefonnummer dann
weitergeleitet haben oder wo dann
irgendeinen sägt er in oder so sitzt und
gegebenfalls das telefon beantwortet
dass die frau von der abnimmt wer ist
dieser ingo daniel erinnert sich schon
einmal auf den namen ingo gestoßen zu
sein
bei der analyse der website das volk
gegen korona alle unterseiten wurden von
dennis haberschuss erstellt mit einer
ausnahme der quellcode verrät der nutzer
ingo erstellte offenbar eine seite auf
der es um klagen gegen die korona
maßnahmen geht doch weder im impressum
der initiative noch im handelsregister
der firma findet man einen ingo aber die
niederländische nummer führt uns zu
seinem telefonanschluss
naja jetzt kann ich nicht mehr
abstreiten dass er was mit dieser
initiative zu tun hat und dann holt sie
ihn auch noch ans telefon
ich verstehe nicht was sie von mir
wissen wollen auf der website steht
alles drauf dass es selbst erklärt warum
steht dort dass sie spenden in den
genannten sammeln das gehört zum
operativen geschäft dazu sage ich nichts
und wie können ihren anwalt erreichen
das sage ich nicht
ingo streitet am telefon nicht ab etwas
mit das volk gegen korona zu tun zu
haben
er wirbt sogar dafür auf seiner website
auf anfrage zu einem interview erhalten
wir keine antwort wenn ich bei einer
recherche einen namen habe dann gebe ich
den in einer reihe von datenbanken ein
um herauszufinden was die person noch so
gemacht hat die im patentamt
hinterlegten adressen bringen uns zu den
männern die hinter das volk gegen korona
stehen demnach hat dennis haberschuss im
sommer 2020 eine marke für
nahrungsergänzungsmittel angemeldet
zusammen mit einem zweiten mann ingo
endlich ein durchbruch
es wird zeit nach südhessen zu fahren um
die hintermänner der vermeintlich
größten klage in der geschichte
deutschlands zur rede zu stellen
bad könig im odenwald kreis hier soll
deines haberschuss wurden wir stellen
denn es haberschuss mehrere fragen zu
seiner rolle bei das volk gegen korona
er droht uns mit der polizei und
verschwindet in sein haus wie dennis
haberschuss wohnt auch ingo in bad könig
nicht auf unsere fragen antworten und
bei ihm zu hause treffen wir ihn nicht
an
frustriert waren wir zurück nach berlin
ein letzter versuch führt uns zurück zu
den prominenten schirmherren die mit
ihren gesichtern vertrauen schaffen
wollen für viele menschen sind
schirmherren letztlich die entscheidende
vertrauens brücke zu einer organisation
und spenderinnen und spender müssen dann
davon ausgehen können dass sich diese
schirmherren vorher gewissenhaft und der
funktionsweise in dieser spendensammlung
überzeugt haben haben sie das ende
oktober im corona hotspot berlin
tausende anhänger in der querdenken
bewegung demonstrieren in der hauptstadt
wir wissen dass auch ralf ludwig und
bodo schiffmann ihr sind die hoffen am
rande der veranstaltung antworten auf
unsere fragen zu erhalten
auf der demo kommt es zu ausschreitungen
der ton wird rauer udo schiffmann macht
mit seiner corona im kultur halt kann
brandenburger tor
wir haben ihn im vorfeld um ein
interview gebeten aber keine antwort
erhalten wird er mit uns über den
verbleib der spenden für das volk gegen
korona sprechen
statt antworten nur ausflüchte keine
spur von transparenz auf ihrer website
behauptet das volk gegen korona firma
und konto im ausland sollten die spenden
vor staatlichem zugriff schützen
am ende der demo fragen wie ralf ludwig
noch einmal nach dem auslandskonto für
die spenden und seiner rolle ludwig sagt
mit der verwaltung des geldes im ausland
sei alles in ordnung
es ist ja einen vertrag wo irgend jemand
seine kunden hat ist ja mir erst mal
egal die firma die quasi das geld da
einsammelt das ist alles ganz normal das
ist ist ja auch europäisches konto also
wissen sehen davon dass dennis
haberschuss auch raichs bürger tweets
verfasst hat dass er was vor fast aus
der reichs bürger tweets verfasst hat
und den er
donald trump auf fordert die deutsche
regierung dominieren
wir zeigen ihnen den tweet von dennis
haberschuss an donald trump
man muss natürlich differenzieren diese
leute pauschal als recht zu bezeichnen
was häufig passiert halte ich für falsch
solange der der dahinter steht kein
straftäter ist und nichts strafbares
macht sehe ich das nicht als
problematisch an das volk gegen korona
das ist ein symbol in der ich stehe wo
ich mein kopf und mein gesicht ist das
ist eine seite des berges sauber in der
spur des geldes für ein volk gegen
khoren erfolgt erhält nur vage antworten
keine spur von transparenz der reichs
bürgern fragt stößt auf gleichgültigkeit
wenn es unbequem wird wollen die
verantwortlichen nicht sagen
wir haben hier eine gruppe von menschen
in der gesamtbevölkerung die
verschwörungs ideologien offen vertritt
die nicht mehr erreichbar ist für fakten
der mehrheitsgesellschaft die nicht mehr
bestimmte medien anschaut die
wissenschaft nicht mehr vertraut und das
wird uns als gesamtgesellschaftliches
problem erhalten bleiben kurz bevor wir
unseren film fertigstellen tut sich dann
doch noch was auf der homepage von das
volk gegen korona neue unterstützer
ihnen kommen hinzu
aber die intransparenz bleibt die rolle
von dennis haberschuss und seiner firma
medical research systems bleibt auch
weiterhin für den besucher unklar
was denkt ihr wird ihr politischer
protest missbraucht um geld zu machen
schreibt es uns in die kommentare
[Musik]